[ __ ] your wife dude wow
that's that's so [ __ ] weird dude the
mom
[ __ ] her up
it's the mom's fault
what's up chris and matt
so my wife was raised to believe that
santa claus
and believing in santa claus is bad that
your parents are lying to you wow while
on the other hand i was raised
allowed to believe in him and and
just thought it was a fun and magical
part of my childhood i didn't think of
it as being lied to
um
when i was
dating my wife
uh
her mom
asked me so how do you feel about your
parents lying to you oh my god oh all of
your childhood oh and that like really
hurt me like yeah because i was just
thinking about all the fun memories that
i had about
their like
playing this santa claus character and i
had no problem with it yep um
and it continues in that she doesn't
want yeah our son to
have like the santa claus experience and
i'm like is this worth
arguing about in the first place
santa claus
let me know what you guys think oh
that is one of the best that is the best
question yeah we've gotten so far and
the way he did it too was really nice
the way he said it all of it it was just
like the way he said was very concise
and good i mean it wasn't that concise
that was a pretty long video what do you
i didn't think it was that long but
mostly one in the beginning of it i was
thinking about other stuff
okay so you know what he said uh not
really i know he said they think about
santa here's the deal i
okay i don't like when people and my
therapist agrees with this
because we were talking about what's
that thing where they hook up all the
stuff to your brain edmr therapy emrd or
whatever the [ __ ] it's called
anyway
it brings up traumas that you don't
necessarily know that you have and it
helps you work through them and brings
them to the surface now my therapist
says there's two thoughts of it some of
them people think it's good because it
brings all your traumas to the surface
and you get to work through it but some
therapists think it's bad because
sometimes your brain is protecting you
from remembering those traumas correct
and you don't necessarily need to work
through them because you forget them and
that's okay so here's the thing this
guy's living his life having a good time
loving santa claus and then all of a
sudden this [ __ ] mom is like hey how
do you think about your family lying to
you and he's like oh i don't really
think of it that way and she's like well
you know that's what it is technically
and she's basically turning something
that was beautiful into something like
no you really need to think about this
and she's [ __ ] him up that's not on
her that's not him and he should be able
to raise his kid the way he wants to
raise her but it's her kid too i know so
here's the deal
say no stand your ground
why no he's the way he asked it was
right he's like is this really something
to put my foot down about [ __ ] santa
claus bro the kid is going to be shunned
in school
no he's going to be the one that
everyone that is going to be like
ruining it for everybody i know they're
going to be they're going to use the
[ __ ] no no he's gonna be the popular
one because he knows
i don't know it's it's [ __ ] up that
what the [ __ ] is wrong with your wife's
parents dude that's really weird i mean
it is lying but if they're not christian
then i get it but like if they're
christian and they're just like [ __ ]
no we tell no lies
what about all the christian [ __ ] well
that's lies they believe in it though i
know what the [ __ ] he should have
spun it back in his face wow what about
the [ __ ] about jesus rising from the
dead you believe that [ __ ]
yeah on [ __ ] easter every [ __ ] day
you idiot every every year you idiot
right so not the way to have that
conversation no he should have flung it
back in his wife's mom's face uh what i
think is it a christian thing did he say
that
no he didn't
but i'm saying
i'm saying the thing i'm saying uh which
is different than what he said right
which is
honestly you should be saying that no no
because i say
he says things yeah and then i say
different things in response to it i
mean i i get it yeah okay
that's what the show is all right
uh i don't think that
i think your your wife's mom is super
[ __ ] up
i think that your wife was sort of kind
of deprived into a weird [ __ ] way of
a fun thing it's just fun like [ __ ]
whatever yeah and i but i also think
don't [ __ ] fight about who gives a
[ __ ] really yeah dude who cares dude i
would go nuts if my wife didn't want
calvin to
have santa claus who cares just get him
[ __ ]
presents i mean i guess but it's like
what about the magic of it and it's so
sweet are you wait you grow up and
you're like oh yeah okay i get it
everyone was kind of just it was a thing
for a kid
kids it's not like it [ __ ] sounds
everywhere you
i got all this [ __ ] [ __ ] in the
back of my nose but it's like i got ants
back there but um
yeah it's like nobody thinks
it's insecure nobody thinks that like
they're lies like this is something
that's wrong with the the mother that's
what i'm saying like nobody's lying to
the kids but here's the thing the wh the
wife you interrupt me
the wife got [ __ ] up
yeah by the mom
yeah so it's not the wife's fault right
so just go with what the wife wants
because she's beyond [ __ ] up because
the mom
[ __ ] her up
it's the mom's fault yes
so let the wife let the wife [ __ ]
have it the way she wants yeah because
she's already beyond [ __ ] up yeah
and i guess [ __ ] up your kid but with it
and everything too and
perpetuate the [ __ ] upness i mean the
worst [ __ ] therapist go ahead and
perpetuate the [ __ ] up it's like
they're gonna fight about it yeah i
guess if there's gonna be a fight about
it just make sure that you can just get
your kids presents
and make sure that they can include
themselves in the day but i guess it's
not worth it if your wife's gonna be
[ __ ] crazy and be like hey no no
santa claus in our house because it's a
lie you know what i mean yeah you're
always like wearing makeup that's not
really how you look that's a lie too how
about do that yeah say that oh you wear
[ __ ] pumps you're not that tall what
about that you lied about that like
where's the line that was yeah where's
the line
either don't wear pumps or they're santa
which one something bad happened to the
mom when she was a kid of a center you
know yeah no [ __ ] man
but
unfortunately i mean you know what the
more i [ __ ] think about it
[ __ ] your wife dude wow
that's that's so [ __ ] weird dude you
want to do the thing to make your kid
happy you should be able to do it you're
not lying remember when mom told us
there was no santa claus and then dad
was mad because they obviously didn't
have that conversation together and that
dad the next year said you know so maybe
there is santa claus because we didn't
even know you want that you wanted that
but we but he still got it for you santa
knew and i was like yeah i know what
you're doing dude i i don't remember
that how old were we we were doing like
a [ __ ] way too old you know and mama
was like you know there's not really
santa and we're like oh really oh yeah
okay and then
later on my dad was like yeah you know
mom said there wasn't no santa i was
like yeah and she was like well you
didn't tell us that you wanted that
right i was like no and he's like did
you want that and i was like yeah
then he's like well santa knew and that
must be santa and i'm like ah all right
man we're like we're in a suit yeah
we're like 22.
uh i remember i was like i was like 12
and i i
like cornered mom and dad yeah like
you're gonna [ __ ] tell me wow that
there is no santa claus i know there is
no santa claus you're gonna tell me and
they wouldn't do it
they still they would not do it i was
like you guys are being so weird i know
i [ __ ] know how did you know there is
no because i because i was i was [ __ ]
basically an adult alright and i
understood that there's no guy who
brings [ __ ] presence to every only
christian household and goes down the
chimney and is a fat [ __ ] he needs
cookies all night yeah okay i still knew
that i believe in him okay well sorry to
break it to you but he doesn't exist
hello
hello
[Music]